is your political career over Mr Johnson
Boris Johnson finds himself on the
defensive again people in the UK might
want to hear you speak on a matter that
matters to them Mr Johnson was
confronted by Sky News about the
allegations as he made his way through
the airport in Washington DC you've been
accused of Breaking the Law at Checkers
and at Downing Street did you no but uh
you'll look
um it's there if it's proved that you
did are you finished as a politician
the answer is that
um
as I said before there was absolutely no
rule breaking and you know
what proof do you have of that
well look you know those who want to
make allegations should make allegations
and so far nobody has and you're my
honest view I think this whole thing is
completely nonsensical
Mr Johnson's ministerial diary revealed
visits by friends to Checkers during the
pandemic details of the trips to the
country residents Come Just As a public
inquiry into covid begins I think that
it's ridiculous that elements in my
diary should be cherry-picked and handed
over to
uh the police to the Privileges
committee uh without even anybody having
the the basic common sense
to ask me what these entries referred to
what do they refer to there is
absolutely nothing in those entries that
constitutes uh rule breaking during
covid restrictions okay mingling with
friends at Checkers note that is
absolutely not what those diary entries
show
Mr Johnson was referred to the police by
the cabinet office earlier on in the
week
here in Westminster of course there is
already an investigation into whether
Boris Johnson knowingly misled
Parliament when he denied having
lockdown parties these new claims could
prolong that investigation and inflict
more damage on the former prime minister
a spokesman for the Privileges committee
said the committee received additional
written evidence from the government on
the 18th of May on the 19th of May this
was sent to Mr Johnson to enable him to
respond the committee will take this
evidence and Mr Johnson's response into
account when considering its final
report
but critics of the former prime minister
say this is now proving to be a
distraction from the big issues people
face in the country well we have to know
exactly what went on and it's yet more
example of why Boris Johnson wasn't fit
to be prime minister and frankly I don't
think he's fit now to be a member of
parliament he's from Sky News he's from
Sky News he's been he's entitled to ask
me questions he says new claims that he
broke covered restrictions on nothing
more than an attempt to stitch him up
somebody somewhere thinks it's sensible
to do this I don't take care of us
something these claims could spell the
end of Boris Johnson's colorful and
controversial political career
others know better than to write him off
Nick Martin Sky News Westminster